Let's scroll up a little more to look at the second half of the problem.
Now, that we've got all the preliminaries out of the way,
how do we actually launch a kernel on the GPU?
Here's a new piece of syntax in Cuda, the Cudalaunch operator.
the Cuda launch operator is indicated by these three less than signs
and these three greater than signs with some parameters in the middle.
This line says launch the kernel name square on one block of 64 elements.
Then the arguments to the kernel are two pointers, d out and d in.
This code tells the CPU to launch on the GPU 64 copies of the kernel on 64 threads.
Note that we can only call the kernel on GPU data, not CPU data.
Since we named our GPU data to start with d_,
we can visually see that we've done the right thing.
Then when we're done with the kernel, the results are in d_out on the GPU,
and this cudaMemcpy call will move memory from device to host and place it in h_out.
The next thing we do is print it out, okay?
We're just walking through the h_out array.
We're printing four things per line.
We're putting tabs in and then a new line after 4,
and then we free the memory that we allocated on the GPU and return 0.
That's all the CPU code.
There's a fair amount in boilerplate in here. It looks fairly similar for most programs.
Most programs are going to have you create some data on the CPU,
allocate some data on the GPU,
copy memory from CPU to GPU,
launch some kernels that will run on the GPU,
copy the results back to the CPU,
and then continue to process them, print them, and so on.